so what I want to do here is try another
one punch man video would rather than
speculating a battle between Saitama and
a comic-book character instead we're
going to reference a fanfiction manga
where one punch man finds himself thrown
into a conflict against none other than
Vegeta now while this is fairly short
I'm hoping you come away with this with
a good idea regarding the kinds of
future conflicts we might see if fans
choose to delve further into this method
of storytelling so while I haven't been
able to trace down the roots of who
created this manga besides the fact that
it's a fan of anime and the manga genre
after surfing the front page of Reddit
once all the links were purple I did
some research and found the story was
originally created in Japanese and
translated by a reddit user named Orson
Templar having said that instead of
being a lower quality fanfiction on par
with the way one punch man was
originally drawn instead this story is
done exceptionally well and is probably
as close as I've seen to accurate
orianna's original artwork so with the
story opening up we actually joined
Vegeta in the middle of an afternoon
training session where normally Vegeta
will be training within his own facility
because boa wears the pants in the
family Vegeta was kicked out so that
trunks could receive training from a
visiting teacher now while it's entirely
possible that trunks is indeed being
trained by a teacher this most likely
means that Boas knocking the boots with
somebody else
however while in the midst of training
Vegeta is suddenly met by Saitama who's
looking for a supermarket now the funny
thing about this fanfiction is that a
treat Saitama is if he's been there the
entire time and it simply just stumbled
upon Vegeta in the midst of training in
addition to this keeping in line with
his character as he's depicted in the
Dragon Ball series Vegeta is extremely
arrogant and that he initially dismisses
Saitama without much thought now we'll
get into more discussion about the
character of Agito later on but because
he had developed the ability to sense
power levels rather than being stupid
and relying on Scouters like Frieza and
his ilk once could you to take some
millet to pay attention he realizes this
saitama's power level is over 9000
actually he just says it is overwhelming
but it would be awesome if he did say
that it was over 9000 but continuing
with this line of thought something that
I hope you notice here is that VG's
response is actually the same as when
you make Goku for the first time what I
mean here is that for those of you who
have never seen Dragon Ball Z which is
kind of a stretch because I don't know
anybody who hasn't seen it yet but for
those of you who have not seen Dragon
Ball Z when we derived on earth for the
first time following the deaths of
piccolo tien katsu and Yamcha Goku had
arrived from his training with King Kai
and the speed at which he moved gave us
our first experience with a surprise 4G
deface while this bit of an appearance
isn't the most important thing on the
planet the fact that Vegeta takes a
notice of saitama's extreme and
seemingly limitless power is a nice nod
to both the beginnings of the Dragon
Ball series as well as fans of the one
punch man anime and manga what's also
cool here is that the original author
actually writes Vegeta almost perfect
again where we had previously touched on
the arrogance of his character I want to
sort of highlight this again as a
combination of pride and arrogance as
well as courage and ambition and a lot
of ways Vegeta represents the very
essence of what it means to be driven
and motivated on the other hand the
nature of Saitama on a personal level is
also included here stepping back for a
second on the whole Saitama is a
character that suffers from an
existential crisis and that his extreme
abilities have given way to the question
that if no one can beat him what's the
purpose of his role in life this stands
in stark contrast to characters like
Vegeta whose sole purpose is to surpass
Goku and that the introduction of any
challenger as a means to achieve this
goal is someone worth fighting in
addition to this the author of this
manga continues a standard approach of
providing fast cutting scenes with a
little dialogue providing emphasis on
the impact of the characters as they
block attacks but the dialogue that we
do receive leans a little more to the
Dragon Ball Z side of things that
anything else the reason why is that in
the Dragon Ball Z universe whenever
fights take place in either the anime or
the manga particular focus is placed on
providing us as the viewer with the
perspective of the individuals involved
for Vegeta the fact that one punch man
is as strong as he is begs the question
of how someone with such extraordinary
ability could exist on
earth especially considering that the
sands are largely considered to be the
dominant force in the universe
but first hi Tama because the
introduction of the story came without
an explanation of how we got there we
could only assume that within the
confines of this crossover the two share
a single universe and that while Saitama
himself has faced off against an
incredibly powerful villains the
strength of Vegeta provides a challenge
he hasn't faced before
however something to note here is it up
to this point
Saitama has not physically punched
Vegeta and is simply been blocking his
attacks which goes to the idea that his
ability to defeat beings in a single
punch
has not been explored what we do get to
see though is the fallout of Vegeta
using his Galligan attack now I
personally would have gone with the
final flash since that is just an
awesome name for an attack
but when medida deploys a Galligan
Saitama temporarily shifts his focus
from being casual to being serious and
attribute very similar to Goku what I
mean here is that in the Dragon Ball
series Goku is well known as a character
that can switch from being silly to
serious at the drop of a hat and where
this seems to be an element present in a
lot of different animes and manga it
seems to have become a hallmark of
Goku's character and so where I wouldn't
say that the author is trying to draw a
parallel between the two I will say that
at the very least it's interesting to
see and so let Saitama deflecting the
Galligan what the author is telling us
is that in truth Vegeta is woefully
outmatched
this comes in both the statement of
Saitama that he found the attack to be
impressive and Vegeta's reaction after
filming is all into the Galligan only to
find out that not only did Saitama
survive but he has sustained no damage
whatsoever now this is a bit of writing
that would appear to polarize some
readers and the following with
expectations Dragon Ball Z fans would
refuse to believe that Saitama could
withstand this attack while one punch
man fans would maintain that he easily
could but to be honest I wouldn't take
this depiction as gospel truth or an
absolute indication of who's more
powerful I'd simply take it as the
author's interpretation but what this
basically means is a Saitama is more
powerful
furthermore when Vegeta demands to know
how Saitama reached such a high level of
strength the reply of running ten miles
and performing 100 push ups sit ups and
squats every single day goes
unbeliev especially in the face of
vegeta having trained 450 times Earth's
gravity and experience that would dwarf
saitama's regimen if you choose to side
with the anime and so with the g2
preparing to power up and become a Super
Saiyan the battles cut short when the
boss calls informing Vegeta that
dinner's ready
recognizing his place in the bigger
picture Vegeta brings things to an end
by informing Saitama that he has to head
home and so as the comic lines down
Vegeta extends an olive branch by
swapping digits under the intention that
the two get together another time and
finish their conflict with that being
said we're going to bring this video to
an end and let me know down in the
comments section how you guys felt about
this video did you love it
did you love it more and I will catch
you guys later peace